are we ready to live with covid here in
the uk i think we are getting ready to
live with covert we are going to have to
live with this
virus we can find a way to live with
this virus as we head into another year
of the pandemic the uk government
appears to be looking for an exit route
i hope will be one of the first major
economies to demonstrate to the world
how you transition from pandemic to
endemic there have been talks of ending
repeat mass vaccination abandoning free
rapid testing and reducing
self-isolation times so could we learn
to live with covid and what would that
look like in the uk
[Music]
covid isn't going anywhere and since the
start of the pandemic experts have said
we must adapt our lives in order to meet
the challenges that come with the virus
let's break that down to see what it
could mean
get boosted now slow the spread of
omicron in the uk more than 80 percent
of people over 12 have had two
vaccinations and 33 million boosters
have been given
yes congratulations
the fact that omicron appears to be
milder than previous variants has led
the government scientific advisors to
say that a fourth covid vaccination
isn't needed right now
what does that mean in the long run
could we perhaps see yearly coveted
vaccinations for those most at risk
becoming the norm
some scientists have warned that giving
boosters to people every six months
wouldn't be sustainable and that more
jabs shouldn't be offered until there's
more evidence
in future covid might even be treated
like any other illness such as flu if
you feel unwell stay at home otherwise
carry on as normal there's also the
question of testing free lateral flow
tests were first made available to
everyone in england last april but
there's been debate recently about
whether they'll be scrapped although
some ministers have said that free rapid
tests will absolutely not be charged for
housing secretary michael gove has
refused to deny they could be phased out
in the coming weeks
one of the biggest challenges brought
about by the pandemic has been to our
professional lives the last couple of
years have seen many of us working from
home in an attempt to contain the spread
of the virus that's still the
government's advice where possible but
is it here to stay
research shows that 25 of jobs
advertised in december last year
mentioned hybrid working or flexible
hours that's up from 19 before the
pandemic the government is now being
urged to change the law so that large
companies make all vacancies available
on a flexible basis what started as a
temporary measure could have changed the
working landscape forever
[Music]
along with social distancing mask
wearing has been one of the main
approaches to curbing the transmission
of the highly contagious coronavirus in
england face coverings are currently
required by law in most indoor public
places and on public transport but the
rules are due to be reviewed
so will we have to wear them forever
masks have long been a common sight in
asia to prevent the spread of illness
but will the rest of the world follow
suit and adopt them as a regular fixture
time will tell
some experts have suggested face
coverings should remain indefinitely as
part of the public's defense against
other viruses and infections but it may
be more likely to become a matter of
personal choice than the law
and finally with the uk gearing up to
find an exit route to the pandemic is
england's outlook shared across the uk
the short answer is no the first
minister of wales has said that the
strategy in westminster is not just out
of step with the rest of the uk but also
the rest of europe and while there's
hope that will come to live with the
virus some scientists point out the
pandemic won't just transition into an
endemic because the government wills it
not least at a point when infections are
running at the highest level
there are still many uncertainties to
the uk's journey out of this pandemic
but one thing that's clear is the
intention to move away from avoidance
towards coexistence whatever that looks
like